[Music]  they know it one hot dog with mustard  please there's a whole bunch of people  in the modern city and all of them have  to be fed all right thanks buddy okay  you're welcome all right for everything  we don't eat everything we leave behind  there is a lot of hungry critters that  are waiting to get to it  [Music]  [Music]  believe it or not if you added up all  the food that is consumed by ants on the  streets of Manhattan it would be the  equivalent of 60,000 hotdogs per year  [Music]  these guys are actually providing a  vital service for us because by eating  up all this waste food they are limiting  the number of rats and pigeons in the  city that could be carrying nasty  diseases  [Music]  [Music]